are you ready
Z I'm Swiss beans my reputation as a
renowned multiplatinum music producer
runs parallel to my passion for cars my
son n and I will set out on a journey to
explore different car coaches across the
globe I'm happy to be here with my
father it's important to me that Nas
understands our community's experience
transform my life with the drive we have
in common I come from Les means I'm
where I'm at today because I learned how
to work with what I have and these
brothers they working with what they
have this idea of
[Music]
community is where we're strongest to
see a father and son Duo like this
Father and Son Duo super inspiring
absolutely I need this one move the
dining room
table offroading ever since I was a kid
I dreamed about it you guys changed our
lives
Drive is about family love inspiring
community that passion never
stops we Ain had this in the Bronx fire
bro are you ready to learn how to drive
stick yeah it's about
time make sure my seat belt is
[Music]
tight